Holy crap, that's the coolest thing ever
Yes, we're just three episodes away from the season finale of American Gods and I'm here to help break down the episode and point out
Some of the cool things you may have missed along the way so put on your Ted Nugent
bandana
Because here we go
the episode begins backstage at what appears to be some sort of vaudeville show these types of shows featured a variety of
entertainers like mimes and they were popular from about the 1890s to
1930s and we get our first American Gods musical number
Check out the background of the set, which is a rendition of the Great Hall in Valhalla. Mr
Wednesday even announces that the name of the hall therein is the Regis which is derived from an Icelandic codex
Which holds many old norse poems it's a fitting name since this theaters in the business of song and dance
and of course
We have Wednesday's
Ravens mutant and Hugin watching over we then get our first glance of doner the great who will later find out is actually
Thor he carries Thor's hammer Mjolnir, we also get a glimpse of Miss Colombia decked out in her American flag costume
Colombia deriving from Christopher Columbus who discovered America
Although was actually the Vikings hundreds of years before him after the show ends
Wednesday is congratulated by the crowd. But the most interesting thing is this mysterious man who will later find out his technical boy
We then have a few Nazis arrive
And yes Nazis were more public in America before World War two, so it isn't out of the realm of possibility
But it was all a memory inside. Wednesday's head while he dreams
They're outside Gamora a mall built over the Dwarven center of power
Last episode mentioned Sodom and it's interesting that they now bring up Gomorrah
Since both were cities mentioned in the book of Genesis renowned for their sin and vice
They're here to see Valen who they need to reforge the runes on Odin's spear gun near fun fact
I used to live near this actual mall, and it even has a little theme park inside it too
The closing of the mall is also a metaphor for the old gods slowly dying away
They haven't even gotten rid of the banner that says the future is 1989
But the most important part of this scene is when Wednesday tells shadow
He reminds him of his son donar the Great and we'll get into that in a bit back at blackbriar. Mr
World has a cool little diagram depicting quote small attacks that may light the spark. He's likely referring to events
That will sway more people to his side
He then has a chat with new media telling her a cryptic message that victory requires a power of breadth and scope
She says she'll up her game and turns into a cat emoji this character back at the Regis. Mr
Nancy works backstage telling Columbia
She's got to go on he also has some deal with her that he gets 20% of her worshippers
But Columbia is busily oiling up donar who says that he can't run a way with her to California
because Wednesday needs him but Columbia says Wednesday is just using him and she alludes to her being the Wild West and
Manifest destiny manifest destiny being the idea that the United States was destined by God to expand across the continent
No wonder she wants to go west to California in the main theater
Wednesday tries to make nice with technical boy by giving him his best showgirls a Samba and goof unis
I couldn't find any details on a Samba but goo foon was the ancient Norse goddess of agriculture and fertility
Technical boy isn't enjoying the hospitality and shows tremendous hubris in the face of Wednesday who remarks that he may be gaining followers now
But what happens when his technology becomes obsolete?
Foreshadowing his eventual demise when new media and mr
G take over this scene also sets up what could be technical boy?
Joining the side of the old gods
Stone are shows off his strength again with more illusions that he's Thor with the girls unable to lift his sacred hammer
hammer vogner's ride of the Valkyries plays in the background while Wednesday keeps tabs on tech boy a man named manfred inquires about
Donar but Wednesday wants to know why he wears the angle cross of Phil fought on his arm band the angle cross of Phil fought
Was used centuries before the Nazi version of the swastika adorning sword hilts and funerary urns largely a religious symbol
Manfred says he's with the Friends of new Germany, which was an actual organization in the United States in the 1930s
Which sought to bolster support abroad for the Nazi Party back at the dead Maul?
Century says that de Valen isn't capable of forging the runes the strength to etch
Such runes of war would require great power which only the leather jacket worn by Lou Reed
Can provide at the Regis Manfred wants to sponsor donar for the world weightlifting competition which Wednesday thinks is a great idea
Donar will be elevated to his former glory which in turn will elevate the entire pantheon of old gods
We also see how much sway Odin has in. His son's decision while Colombia isn't too pleased
Nazis frighten her. It's also interesting here to note how they're setting up donor as a
Sympathetic character who dreams of running off with Colombia telling her that once he wins they can move to
California and do whatever they want. Of course. This does not have a happy ending
we then get another musical number as Colombia sings about not being fenced in a
metaphor for the expansion of America through the Wild West but it begs the question what happens to Colombia when there's no more places to
conquer no more lands to explore Bishop Hammersmith over here buys, Lou Reed's jacket for
$7,500, but it's all a ruse shadow barges in posing as Secret Service taking in Wednesday for using fake bills
And of course the jacket is now evidence so they walk away scot-free
In a backroom filled with creepy mannequins shadow and tear gates Wednesday about his son
we learned that he was indeed Thor but he went by his given name donar a
Particular interest is how Wednesday says shadow reminds him of donar that they share similar characteristics
But the death of donar is too painful for Wednesday to bring up
My guess is that this all links to why Wednesday hasn't revealed himself to be shadows father
He could have distanced himself from him in order to avoid being hurt the way he was when he lost donor but at the same
Time as I theorize Daffy you episodes ago. He could also not be revealing it in order to protect shadow
We then get a flurry of newspaper and radio ads depicting donor strength and eventual rise to fame. It confirms that this is
1934 and that he seems to be quote harnessing the power of the gods
I also like how the articles themselves are written in Latin
Manfred talks to donar about a proposal which donar isn't too pleased about man Fred wants donar to purposely loses matchup with the German
Competitor mister Nancy appears and let me first say that I am loving Orlando Jones. He's just killing it this season
He tells donar the story of a young boy born to a world where men could not rule so this boy traveled through time
To find a world where men could he made a deal with man?
Exchanging fire from the gods for the ability to rule which the men then used to find his homeland and destroy it his own
lust for power destroyed
The very thing he loved and that's what Nancy is getting at donar made a deal with the Germans and is now paying the price
for it just like Nancy did who was the boy in that story do Valen has given the sacred power of Lou Reed and now
given the strength is able to reforge the runes claiming that it's now ready to be healed as soon as this happens the alarms that
Blackbriar go off alerting, mr. World that the runes have been
He says that things are going ahead of schedule, but that his friends in the valley will be ready
He's referring to Silicon Valley and whatever scheme he has cooked up with mr
G back in the 1930s donor decides that after his last show. He's gonna move with Columbia to California
He says he's going up pledge himself to her and I think that distinct use of the word pledge here evokes the Pledge of Allegiance
He's pledging himself to America. Of course
Muna and Hugin are watching Wednesday introduces Columbia to technical boy who has a proposition
To reform Columbia into Our Lady of the war effort ever since Lady Liberty came into the picture. Columbia has slowly been losing followers
Shield need this if she's going to survive and Our Lady of the war effort would be a perfect fit for Miss manifest destiny
Over here because believing God has chosen America to win. The war would be a huge advantage now
I also think it's interesting that Libertas
The Roman god of freedom is brought up again here a huge emphasis was placed on it in Episode two
And I had the crazy theory that shadows mother could potentially be Libertas herself
Check out my episode 2 video if you want to know a little bit more about that
Columbia needs more time to think about it since she just decided that night
She's going out west with donar but Wednesday tells her that he left with the Germans without her which of course is alive
he tells her it's time to manifest her own destiny a cheeky nod to her being the
encapsulation of manifest destiny
and in the background
you can faintly hear America the Beautiful playing in the alleyway of the Regis Wednesday confronts donor who has decided not to do the
championship instead running off with Columbia
But Wednesday tells him she won't be coming and they get in one of the coolest
Scenes of the series young year and Mjolnir Duke it out with mule near so powerful
It shatters Wednesday spear in half. Seriously. This is the kind of stuff
I've been wanting to see in this series since season 1 God's battling it out using their weapons and powers
Wednesday is so shocked at how powerful donar is stating that it's only a fraction of what's to come
He tells them that power like this you cannot walk away from but that's exactly what he does and in
1942 donar commits suicide
the only death gods can't come back from
Notice this somewhere in America painted in blood and they we can do it rosie the riveter Poe
Derr which has been superimposed with the face of Colombia suggesting that Columbia took technical boys offer and donar lost the love of his life
Hence ending his own
Shadow asif dona rode with the Valkyries to the afterlife and Wednesday isn't sure but judging by his face
It isn't likely then the episode ends with Wednesday singing one of the best-known American songs of the Great Depression, brother
Can you spare a dime in what seems like his now rundown theater with donar gone?
He has lost his show and must move on to something new
so where does that leave us with only two more episodes left in the season at the time of writing this the
Promo for episode 7 hasn't yet been released, but it feels like we're getting closer to our big season climax with Goong
You're almost ready and mr. Worlds plans underway. I'm predicting some future
God deaths the reappearance of technical boy and shadows true heritage to be revealed
We also still have Laura's resurrection and her attempt to find this special blood infused with love
I'm really enjoying all the New Gods for being introduced to and excited to see where this season takes us
That's it for this episode guys. I hope you enjoyed it
Be sure to give it a like and subscribe and stay tuned because I'll be coming out with a game of Thrones breakdown
Sometime tomorrow and come check me out on Twitter at think story whitey
Until next time remember daddy loves you very much